Matt Reeves' "The Batman" introduces a brand
new version of the Caped Crusader to audiences,
fleshing out Bruce Wayne in ways fans haven't seen
in live-action before. First, the film forgoes the
typical origin story of that fateful night when
Thomas and Martha Wayne entered Crime Alley.
Instead, it opts to drop on Batman in the
second year of his war on crime in Gotham.
It's a clever way of giving audiences a young,
fresh-faced take on the character without
retreading too much familiar ground. It seems this
narrative decision is working with audiences and
critics alike because "The Batman" has earned
itself a healthy rating on Rotten Tomatoes.
"The Batman" story also introduces a vicious new
version of the Riddler, who is much more of a
homegrown terrorist than Jim Carrey's mischievous
trickster in "Batman Forever." This time around,
the villain's motivation centers around exposing
and punishing the corrupt members of Gotham's
political and legislative infrastructure, starting
with Mayor Don Mitchell, Jr.. Riddler murders
Mitchell in the film's opening, and it's this
brutal act that kicks off a sadistic killing spree
that threatens to unleash utter chaos on Gotham.
With every kill, the Riddler ropes Batman deeper
into a game of cat-and-mouse that gets way more
personal than Bruce Wayne could have imagined.
The Riddler puts the Wayne family in his
crosshairs because he believes Thomas and
Martha Wayne had as much responsibility
for Gotham's downfall as Mayor Mitchell,
the mobster Carmine Falcone, and other
high-profile Gotham figures with shady
backgrounds. The masked killer goes deep into
the truth about the Waynes in a tell-all video,
revealing many dark secrets about Bruce's parents
— including their connection to the Arkham family.
So, how are the Waynes tied to the Arkhams?
In "The Batman," we learn Thomas Wayne married
Martha Arkham. Yes, that's right, Martha is part
of the Arkham family. It's a surprise for fans,
to be sure. Previous live-action "Batman" movies
have never looked at the history of the Waynes
(including those who married into the family)
in great detail. There's the throwaway line
in Christopher Nolan's trilogy about one of Bruce
Wayne's ancestors building an underground railroad
to help slaves escape, which helps explain the
existence of the caves underneath Wayne Manor.
But, aside from that, we don't know much
about the Wayne family tree. Until now.
In "The Batman," the Dark Knight's investigation
leads him to the abandoned orphanage that was
originally supported by The Wayne Foundation
before the untimely deaths of Thomas and
Martha. He's led to the run-down location
after it is mentioned in a shocking video
released by the Riddler that shines a
light on the Waynes in great detail.
The villain explains that Martha was born
into the Arkham family. In her youth, Martha
dealt with mental illness and, per Riddler, had
several stays in the Arkham Asylum to treat it.
The Riddler's video on the Waynes
also reveals that Edward Elliot,
a journalist employed by Sal Maroni, found out
about Martha's past and threatened to expose the
news to derail Thomas' mayoral campaign. Bruce's
father leans on Carmine Falcone for support,
asking the gangster to intimidate the
journalist so the story can stay under wraps.
This is why Riddler targets the Wayne legacy
— it looks like Thomas had Elliot killed.
Anyone even remotely familiar with the Batman
mythos will probably recognize the name
"Arkham" thanks to the notoriety of Arkham
Asylum. Typically, it's Arkham Asylum where
the Caped Crusader sends his opponents after
beating them black and blue in the streets.
Tying Batman directly to Arkham through his
mother's bloodline is an interesting way of
making this new universe feel interconnected,
rather than playing with random chess pieces.
There's also some extensive history
to the asylum in the comics.
The location was first introduced in
1974's "Batman" #258 and was known as the
Elizabeth Arkham Asylum for the Criminally
Insane. Grant Morrison's "Arkham Asylum:
A Serious House on Serious Earth" establishes
that the iconic location was originally founded
by Amadeus Arkham in the early 1900s after
his mother died by suicide. He transformed the
family home into an institution before his wife
and daughter were killed by his first patient,
Martin Hawkins. This eventually drove Amadeus
mad, and he was locked up in his own asylum.
But when it comes to Bruce's mother, her
maiden name is Martha Kane in the comics.
It wasn't until Geoff Johns' "Batman: Earth
One" that DC introduced her Arkham heritage.
She also suffers from mental illness in the
2012 series, and there's also the idea that
Arkham Manor is cursed, supposedly dooming any
future generation to eventual mental illness.
If you or someone you know is struggling with
mental health, please contact the Crisis Text
Line by texting HOME to 741741, or call
the National Alliance on Mental Illness
helpline at 1-800-950-NAMI (6264), or visit the
National Institute of Mental Health website.